[Music]
weren't you into martial arts you were
at a very young age weren't you a black
belt yes I I don't don't be alarmed I I
I've forgotten it all but I I was Lethal
at around 10. I had a black belt how do
you get a black belt at 10 that's hard
to do yeah it took uh it started when I
was five
um so it took it took about five years
and but it starts precisely Well yeah if
you if you're into that whole math thing
yeah so uh so I yeah but I was always
tiny I never you know I wore a double
zero uniform and I was just this tiny
tiny person and the thing was when you
get a black belt they have to everyone
has to bow to you in the studio not in
life I learned that the hard way uh but
they had they have to bow you and call
you call me Mr Helberg um but the thing
was was nobody respected me because I
was a tiny little 10 year old with a
black belt and there was an influx of
these Russian kids that were tough they
they were like tall it was they were
like the Dolph lundgrens to my baby
Balboa and uh and and so they would just
I would come in and I'd be like hello hi
nicodeme you know Leopold Leonid or is
it Leopold okay anyway uh and they'd be
like Willie will look with what we have
here
Simon I'd be like okay well first of all
it's Mr halberg so and I'm gonna need
you guys to Bow I'm gonna have to get
that
just get that out of the way before we
Spar and they'd be like what are you
gonna do about it
I'm going to go tell my master on you
I'll be right back and I would go into
the Master's office and be like okay so
his name was master Gia Kobe he was like
a jersey guy and I'd be like Mr Jacoby
okay so it's it's the Russians again and
they're not respecting my authority
all right I earned the black belt I you
know and he I know he was just trying
not to laugh he'd be like oh okay uh go
uh give pump give him a punishment and
I'd be like a punishment he's like the
20 knuckle push-ups and I'm gonna go out
like Sergey come here come here and they
just they didn't ever uh listen to me at
all and when we would Spar it was no
contact but they contacted me heavily
and uh so you know when you're it's all
about the graceful movements and things
like that and they didn't care they
would just wail on you yeah I mean it
was like and then you know they would
like threat it would work up a threat
you know I would kind of be like first
of all there's no contact
and I think there's threats on the
horizon they're beating you with a trash
can and he's like okay uh 30 knuckle
push-ups I don't know uh yeah so that
that never served me well except it did
I I did I could do the splits uh the
split yeah the like with my legs to the
side and uh and and that was like my big
like a cheerleader
I was gonna say jcvd Jean-Claude Van
Damme more oh okay I'm glad you spelled
that out because they didn't know who
that was thank you well venereal disease
I don't know so yeah I uh so that was my
big things I would go to parties and I
don't know like I'm a little more
insecure now I don't like want to show
off and if somebody's like tell that
story if it comes up but I somehow would
work in doing this I would do the splits
between two chairs at like parties and I
don't know I don't remember how I ever
got into it like how I would just be at
a party and I'd be like okay well uh do
you have another chair I'm like oh yeah
yeah what do you do oh no no it's just
let me just carry on and you know and
I'll just put like one leg I'm just like
just be sitting there just just sit in
the middle of a party like
hi like I have no idea what the process
of getting into people must have hated
you I mean it's ridiculous and like I do
remember parents coming in being like
hey oh my what the like I'm just the
kids sitting on two chairs like oh yes
this I just I'm a black belt and uh you
know you guys enjoy the party yeah I
thought that was like my way into the
late like hey look what I can do look
what's happening here it's literally
here look what's hanging I wish lower
but uh yeah the parents were probably
afraid that a limbo would break out
hello
[Music]
yeah a very dirty limb I was nude too I
guess that might not have helped